so hello everybody we are back with
richard rowland for another universal
history uh moment and this time we're
going to go a little more a lot of
people been asking what are you going to
talk about american stuff american
history because i understand most of us
are in north america and so richard
proposed that we look a little bit at
the symbolism behind groundhog day
this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so we're recording this
it's january the 28th the feast day of
scene from the syrian by the way
um and uh who we're not going to really
talk about today but it is feast day uh
and if you watch this channel then you
probably you know essentially is
important yeah you know he's important
um so it's january the 28th so this
video will probably land sometime
shortly after groundhog day february the
second
um and i've been this is a a topic and a
holiday that i've been fascinated by for
a really long time
and so i thought this would be a fun way
to talk about universal history we are
going to get back to talking about the
grail a little bit more and maybe some
other arthurian stuff in future videos
um but i think that this is maybe an
important thing to talk about because it
shows away
that there is a remnant
uh you could say like a like a ruin
of
a very important aspect of medieval
universal history still present in our
culture today in kind of this goofy way
and
and so i thought it would be kind of fun
for people and i was super excited
because i know nothing about the
original ground like there's a there's a
bill murray movie that is of course uh
pretty famous which we will talk about a
little bit because i think it's
and this is not
before we started recording i said that
some book was like the greatest book
ever and i was being a little facetious
this is not being a little facetious i
think that groundhog day with bill
murray is one of the best movies ever
made
um and i have i have reasons for that
which i'm not gonna really necessarily
get so much into today but as we talk
about the symbolism of groundhog day
you're going to be able to understand
the bill murray movie maybe a lot better
so let's get to it all right so
the immediate the the the
so
because europeans won't know what
groundhog day you have to start with
that oh but europeans are supposed to
know what groundhog okay but i okay all
right go for it okay but let me let me
i'll just explain
what groundhog day is and how we observe
it here in the usfa
um although they actually also do it in
certain places in canada
and certain places it originally comes
from germany uh so it usually comes from
western europe and there's actually even
a version of it in ireland which is
celebrated not on february the 2nd but
on february the 1st which is the feast
day of saint bridget of kildare
so
here's what it looks like in the united
states
there's this weird tradition what
appears to be like kind of like a weird
folk tradition that nobody really
remembers the origins of
and that is that
um
on february the 2nd for some arbitrary
reason on february the 2nd
a groundhog
in other words a marmot
this is it's like a it's like a really
giant fat
ground squirrel um i don't know how it's
to describe it if you have a sequin just
go google that or something um in fact
i was once staying in um
at the ozark heritage center in arkansas
um we went there with our family and
they just had groundhogs everywhere and
they were extremely friendly but
basically it's like if you can imagine a
squirrel without a tail
or it's like a tiny little tail that's
as big as most dogs they're they live on
the ground yeah they live underground
but they'll come out especially like if
they're used to people to come out and
you can feed them and stuff and they're
it's it's scary though because like
they're big they're big yeah they're big
um so the so the idea is and this this
is celebrated particularly at uh one
particular place in in pennsylvania so
we have this very famous groundhog
punxsutawney phil right
and so the the the myth or the kind of
the the folklore is that if the
groundhog comes out of his holes the
idea is he's been in hibernation for the
last you know uh six weeks or so for
winter so if he comes out of his hole
and he sees his shadow then he'll get
scared by it run back into his hole and
go back into another six weeks of
hibernation and that's how you know
that there's going to be six more weeks
of winter if he comes out of his hole
and he doesn't see his shadow then it's
supposed to be an early spring that year
and so that's the folklore and of course
in practice
there's always
he always sees this shadow there's
always six more weeks of winter because
basically we're materialists
and so we make the groundhog conform
to
when we say winter is over
rather than making winter being over
conformed to when the groundhog says
it's going to be over right so he always
eases shadow basically he always sees
the shadow yeah
and so that's the thing and uh in the
united states there there will always be
like a little news story on february the
2nd
affirming whether or not punxsutawney
phil sees his shadow right and then has
to go back in the hole so this is a
really famous uh bill murray movie which
you mentioned uh that was made
kind of based around this concept and so
in this case you have this guy
um
a a newscaster a reporter named phil
played by bill murray um and he's he's
kind of like most of bill murray's
characters right uh you know very kind
of world weary very acerbic
um kind of actually an awful person um
but because he's you know but but always
with this sort of brilliance where they
don't tell you he's an awful person they
just let you pick it up in all these
little ways and you start to realize man
this guy's pretty terrible right
um and basically funny because he's
terrible but funny because he's terrible
right and so basically this this
character this newscaster phil he uh
he
goes to sleep
uh so he so he he has to go out and
and it's on groundhog day on groundhog
day is to go on a groundhog day and do
this fake you know do this fake news
story about the groundhog seeing his
shadow and it's it's stupid it's made up
he hates it he's really upset about it
he treats
all of the people like his producer and
his camera guy and treats them all
really terribly and then wakes up the
next morning and finds out that
he has to repeat the entire day
and he has to repeat the entire day over
and over and over again
until basically he gets it right and in
this case getting it right means he
learns to be
uh
a much more selfless individual
and he learns to um and then he and then
he wins there's some love too he wins
this yeah well he learned still hey
this is very important very important
sounds tacky but it's very important
yeah it sounds it sounds like it's corny
or something like that but it's it's
really important to understanding the
story um is that he learns to
love and and then be loved by this this
woman in his life who had been treating
pretty badly up to that point so i mean
that's it's a great fun movie
um and most people have probably seen it
um and if not like if you're just like
real young and you didn't grow up
watching
that movie then you should go watch it
because i think you'd be surprised how
good it is
so i want to talk about why is this a
thing like
of all the most arbitrary things like i
used to joke that february like just
really got the short end of the stick as
far as months ago because it already has
fewer days and then it just has like a
bunch of seemingly arbitrary made up
stuff going on in it like groundhog day
it's like what's what's this about
well groundhog day
is actually
the one remaining remnant within
american popular culture
of actually a very important holy day
in the history of western europe and the
history of eastern europe as well just
within the christian tradition
um and that's a feast day
in the orthodox church we call it the
meeting of the lord in the temple
in
the western tradition
it's sometimes referred to as the
purification of the blessed virgin mary
or
um more colloquially in the old english
tradition it's called candleness
right the reason it's called candlemas
is because this is the day in the
christian tradition when you
traditionally uh
you get a whole bunch of candles you
either make them or you buy them
and then you bring them to the church
and you bring them to the church
for a couple of reasons one is to give
them in the middle ages you would you
would give
um so they actually had these
these groups of laypeople that would
come together in a guild they were
called candlemas guilds and what they
would do is they would either make or
buy a lot of really really big candles
and then every year on candlemas
they would donate the majority of these
candles to the parish
and it was how the parish i mean candles
were pretty expensive in the middle ages
illumination sometimes they were called
illumination guilds
like illuminating things especially uh
most importantly
illuminating the host at the at the
moment of the elevation so that people
could see it um especially if it's kind
of dark outside there's no electric
lighting things like this this is a this
is a really important function so it was
a way for lay people to serve the
community
uh they would give the candles so that
the church would have candles for the
year right right but then also
they would get their own candles blessed
and so that so the you'd get a holy
candle
and you could take this holy candle home
and if there was sickness in the house
or there were
other reasons to suspect demonic
activity
and i don't say that at all cynically
in fact i have hold on i still have a
handful of my own holy candles left over
from
last last year
so if there's sickness in the house or
some other like hint of demonic activity
you light the holy candle to drive out
the darkness and to drive out uh the
demonic influences
um so so that's why it's
very often referred to as as candlemas
so
the event that this feast celebrates in
the life of christ is of course mary and
joseph coming to the temple
bringing
um bringing the christ child
presenting an offering of two young
turtle dubs
and as they're doing this they're met by
these two figures who kind of
represent
the
you could say like the last of the old
guard
of the righteous remnant of the old
testament so one of them is the elder
simian and there's this whole tradition
about the elders the elder simian that
he's actually several hundred years old
doesn't say this in the bible what it
says in the bible
is that he is uh that the lord had
promised him that he would he was it
just says he's of a great a of a great
age and that the lord had promised him
that he would not die
until he had seen the lord's christ
until he'd seen the messiah
but there's a tradition about him that
says that he's extremely old
um you know several several hundred
years old and that in fact he's one of
the original translators of the
septuagint oh interesting um so there's
this
um maybe the best way to understand that
is simply to say that he's got this
explicit tie to the old testament right
so that he's he's one of those 70 elders
who translated the septuagint into greek
so he's he's got this explicit tie to
the old testament so he's he's um
you could say like the last
guard uh uh the the last
you know oh
i know that technically speaking like
john the baptist is sort of the last old
testament prophet right but you could
see simeon as as also kind of filling
that role to a certain extent right he's
that he's the archetypical last elder of
israel right yeah that the at this point
in time
the faithful people of god in israel
have been
you know it's just a very few it's a
very small remnant and of that small
remnant simian is kind of
you know the type of all of them yeah
and he also if he's the true translator
of the septuagint that he also
represents
something like the last breath of the
old yes old testament
and that will be illuminated by
the candle right we'll be illuminated by
christ and will be revealed like it'll
be revealed for what it is or for what
his purpose is yeah so that there's that
um and of course what does he pray he
says mine eyes have seen your salvation
right a light to be revealed to the
gentiles yeah and the glory of your
people israel so the idea is that you
have something that was the light was
the glory of israel
which could be the torah
right could be the law the old testament
the hebrew scriptures
and then it's revealed to
the gentiles revealed to the nations
sometimes it's translated but it's
really gentiles right
um the light dawning on the gentiles
right and so it's this uh
this this light moving out of a place of
darkness and obscurity into
kind of a more open place right and
attached to this
there is the symbolism of
of attached to this is the prophecy
which
simeon makes about uh to the mother of
god
about her own sorrow at the foot of the
cross
he says that this this you know child
has has been you know brought into this
space brought into the world for the
rising and falling
of many in israel and for a sign that
will be spoken against of course the
sign that will be spoken against is the
crucifixion
um and he says but a sword will pierce
your own heart also
right and so he's talking about the
sword piercing the heart of the mother
of god at the moment of the crucifixion
her anguish and this is like
the the predominant perspective that we
get in orthodox holy week
um is mostly from the the perspective of
the mother of god watching her son
in the lead up to the passion watching
her son on the cross yeah um and so all
of this is is under
it is really important to understand
what's going on in this holiday and i
swear it is in fact connected to
groundhog day
um
well for sure like already yeah you can
see the idea of of the perpetua if you
think understand theophany because often
we we think of theophany as the baptism
of christ but theophany and its more
original symbolism had to do with light
that to do with the revelation of the
divine logos of the light shining onto
the world which made sense after the
birth of christ which is the the
solstice at the at the darkest day where
the the sun is hidden where the the
light is still looks like it's going
down you don't know yet that it's coming
back that it's actually
it's moving up you know right it's it's
moving into its revelation and so to
think of of theophany epiphany as the
first glimmers of that light yeah in the
beginning of the showing of of what has
happened you know on christmas morning
moving in now to
to the the to simeon recognizing and
saying now the light he even uses the
image of the light which will be a sign
so i mean it's very powerful yeah
so we'll come back to the the light in
the darkness here in just a second
because that's really important to this
i do want to point out though that
there's also this particular feast has
these this really explicit
um
if you look at the iconography for this
feast it's very explicitly tied up with
the idea of the temple of the sanctuary
of a holy place and of the reception of
the eucharist and so if you look at
an icon of the feast what you'll
typically see
is the mother of god handing the christ
child to simeon but simeon has his hands
covered with his with his robe
right and if you look at something like
an icon of the communion of the apostles
or something like that you'll see the
same kind of thing in an icon you never
see people taking communion with their
bare hands right they've always got
their hands covered with usually with
like their outer garment or the robe or
something like that to receive the
eucharist right
um and then behind them
uh in the icons of this piece behind
them there's always this very curious
looking structure it's got four pillars
and then a dome usually a dome or kind
of a roof over the top of those pillars
and then very often there's a curtain
that can be drawn around them yeah and
um
so in the tabernacle of moses right
obviously the whole thing is a tent but
then when solomon builds his temple in
the temple of solomon there was this
um
there was this pillared a
pillared curtain right uh so like a tent
inside of the temple basically enclosing
the
the holy of holies right the place where
the ark of god was supposed to rest and
in the ark you're supposed to have the
you know obviously you're supposed to
have the the tables of the law and the
ten commandments or the the tables of
the law and the and the the manna and so
on right well obviously as we've talked
about in this series at some point the
ark went missing right and so at some
point these things are missing from the
holy place the most holy place in in the
temple and they're certainly not present
in the second temple
right by the time of christ right
there's no ark in the temple which is
why the
the
the parallel feast to this feast
um you could say like the four feasts
together have uh i'm gonna try to do a
piece on this for the symbolic world
block so maybe cool
it's already written i just need to like
finish it up but
um
in the winter feast of the church you
have this like chiastic structure where
you have like starting with the entrance
of i keep hitting my microphone starting
with the entrance of the theotokos in
the temple and then going to christmas
and theophany or epiphany and then
finishing right at the presentation of
the lord in the temple right nice yeah
so it's really it's a really nice
structure
um and so at the the parallel feast of
this one the entrance of the theotokos
and the temple that's a big deal because
it's the first time the ark has actually
come to the second temple but anyway
that's a different different video
difference yeah and so so now you have
like the glory descending on right
basically like one of the that type of
imagery yeah so this structure this four
pillar structure with the dome on top
this is a chiborum and as you know
in early christian architecture uh when
christians started being able to build
their own church buildings before
uh the iconostas really develops right
before that really existed what you had
was this chiborum this is this canopy
with a curtain that could be closed at
certain points during the liturgy over
the holy table which by the way the
chiburum you can see it still if you
look at images of the communion of the
apostles usually christ is under a
chiboro
and
the the in the ethiopian church it's
they still most of their altars have
chibuuru like that they're the ones that
i've seen they still use that structure
coptic churches still use that often as
well and there is a there's even a
little bit of a tendency now in in the
modern orthodox churches to reintroduce
it into the practice i saw chiborom
there's one there's one even in in uh in
south carolina at the by the greek
church that i went to where there's some
there are some very old greek churches
like in greece that still have them and
even some very old western churches in
like the netherlands that still have
them yeah yeah um
so
when you see a chiborum
in an icon
right which as you just pointed out
anytime someone is being given communion
in an icon there's always a chiborum in
there somewhere right
so this is a way it's doing two things
one is it's it's this explicit tie from
the jewish temple to the christian
temple right
but then also it's this it's a sort of a
shorthand to tell you something
eucharistic is is happening and kind of
the meaning of this feast right and so
you have um
and so you have sydney in here standing
in front of the chiborum and even you a
lot of times on the on the altar under
the chi borum you'll see a gospel book
which is of course
an anachronism from a like a a purely
like
boring sense of understanding things
right uh but for us we we see it as a
fulfillment what's supposed to be in the
most holy place
that isn't is the tables of the law
right but the tables of the law
in the christian church are replaced by
we don't have a torah scroll in the
altar we have we have the gospels right
so there's this you know kind of all
this all this great symbolism which
again is is part of that thing of like
the the hidden glory of israel now
becoming the light for the gentiles
right
and so uh and so
you've got simeon in the attitude of
someone receiving communion standing
behind in front of this structure which
is all about
the reception of the eucharist all about
communion right and he's receiving the
christ child and if you look at um
if you look at the hymns of the orthodox
church around this feast like the
festive maneon
the they talk about this idea of
of
the use the eucharistic symbolism that's
going on here it's really explicit in
the hymns but then they also tie it back
to another meeting of the lord of the
temple right which is in isaiah chapter
6.
so in isaiah chapter 6 you have a
prophet
who goes to the temple and he meets with
god and in this story what you have is a
prophet who's waiting at the temple
because god isn't there but then god
shows up to the temple right and so it's
kind of this inversion of the isaiah 6
story
and and so there's one of the hymns i
wish that i had uh
was that i had the festival moneon over
here i think it's over on the shelf but
one of him says something like the
seraphim who is mary right so in that in
that story in isaiah chapter six right
isaiah has this vision of god and he
sees him and he says woe is me i'm
undone i'm a man of unclean lips i live
in the midst of the people of unclips
unclean lips for mine eyes have seen the
king the lord of hosts right and so a
seraphim takes one of the takes a pair
of tongs takes one of the coals from off
the the heavenly altar and comes and
touches it to his lips and when he
touches it to his lips he says see this
is you know your sin is taken away your
lip you you've been purged you've been
cleansed right
um and so what the and so the
the the hymns around this feast in the
mineon they
they take that symbolism
and it talks about the seraphim who is
mary brings the burning coal
that is the christ child right and gives
it to the prophet simeon right and at
that point he's able to say now let your
servant depart in peace in other words
i'm ready to die now and in the middle
ages this is very closely uh associated
with the idea uh
this might seem weird to us now except
for those of us you know who are maybe
more traditional christians but even
then like if you're a convert it's hard
to think about things this way
but in the middle ages one of the main
things that people prayed for almost the
only thing that people prayed for if you
were very poor
was that you would you would have enough
anticipation of your death
that you would be able to make one final
confession and receive communion before
you died right they called it like your
uh your
um they would refer to it as like as
like your traveling money in other words
like that that you would be able to
receive the eucharist one last time
before you make the journey right into
the to the next life
and um
and so they saw candleness as being like
sort of an example of this that he
receives christ one last time
before he crosses you know
the river into death yeah and so
um so there's there's uh a bunch of
really cool beautiful eucharistic
symbolism in here and of course in the
orthodox church
uh when priests take communion right
when they give themselves or when they
take communion they say
see this has touched my lips my sins
purge right so they say those words from
isaiah when they receive communion so
there's this really beautiful like kind
of triangulation between the feast of
the meeting of the lord in the temple
and
the meeting of the lord in isaiah
chapter 6
and then the um
and then the reception of communion in
the in the in the ancient church yeah so
i just wanted to point all that stuff
out because it really helps us
understand the symbolism of this feast
and kind of what this feast is about
right this feast it's about illumination
it's about fire it's about
um it's about the the hidden glory right
kind of being i mean it's about light
yeah it's about life
it is definitely about yeah about the
the light manifesting itself more and
more but it's not just about light
manifesting itself because it's always
light that comes with uh
um because there's also an as an element
of it that is actually about a
prediction of darkness
right because because of simeon
right he has this beautiful moment of
light and then he says
he's going to be a sign that is spoken
against he's talking about the passion
yeah and he says the sword is going to
pierce your own heart also so it's it's
this um
it's this
it's a it's also
the promise of darkness is the promise
of a wound but ultimately it's the
promise of pasca right which is which is
the
preeminent christian festival of light
breaking into the world right coming out
of the darkness
so
why february the 2nd
right well obviously february the 2nd is
40 days after
december 25th so it's it's 40 days after
christmas um and so it's the 40 days of
the virgin mary's purification however
february the second i mean you people
don't know anything about this like you
have to just say okay yeah sorry
yeah go ahead that women would have to
would have to purify themselves out of
after a certain amount of time that they
they had to do that regarding their
menstruation but they also had to do it
regarding after giving birth to a child
so according to the law of moses 40 days
after giving birth to the to a child
women were supposed to present
themselves at the the temple of god or
the tabernacle the temple of god
and bring an offering for their
purification
um either you know uh like a young lamb
or if you were if you're
poor then you could bring like two
turtle doves or two young pigeons i
think i think i've read uh from one
historian that like at the time of
christ people only ever brought the the
two birds but anyway
um
and so uh you're supposed to bring an
offering and it's basically uh you could
say it's it
i don't know we probably don't want to
get in this too much but you could just
say like in the old testament and the
mosaic law there are certain things
that bring you very close to life like
this like the beginning of life or very
close to death
and it's like those things are too holy
and so if you're exposed to them or if
you participate at them in some way then
there has to be this
reintegration of you into kind of the
normal
liturgical community like the normal
community of the people of israel right
and so that's what this is about right
birth being extremely close to like the
beginning of life but also very close to
today yeah yeah like both of those
things at the same time
um and so a woman at the end of and we
still do this in the orthodox church
today we there there's you know the
ceremony of churching for
a woman and her child which we're going
to be doing um
here in just a couple of weeks nice
because we just had a just had a baby a
few weeks congratulations yeah thank you
thank you yeah and so um
so all of this
uh all and again like you can even
understand that purification right it's
something that's that's hidden so like a
woman after she has a child she's
supposed to be hidden sequestered
from the community of the people of god
right almost because she's like she's
like too special she's like too holy she
can't she can't yet integrate into the
into the life of the community right and
then at the end of that time that hidden
glory is now revealed into like a more
public kind of a light
um
however
the traditional date for good friday is
of course march the 25th which at one
point in time was the spring equinox i
know that the solstices and equinoxes
they move around a little bit but at one
particular point in time
that was the the traditional date of
both good friday and the annunciation
right is march the 25th
um lots of people out there might want
to like argue about this stuff um all i
can say is i don't care
um
i don't care yeah um this is the this is
these are the traditional dates um
that's all that needs to be said about
it so
what you have to realize is that this
situates the meeting of the lord which
is 40 days after you know this situates
the meeting of the lord or candleness
as being halfway
between the winter solstice and the
spring equinox nice yeah so
to me this is this this sort of reveals
or sort of brings out one of the most
important facets of universal history
okay and this is why this is justly a
universal history video not just richard
talking about you know feasts that he
likes right and groundhog day and
groundhog day
um because one of the most important
elements of universal history
uh is the way
that the is understanding the way that
the christian story
maps onto and it fulfills the sort of
old agricultural cycle of the year which
is present it's not just pagan it's
present both paganism and judaism both
paganism and judaism have this old this
agricultural cycle that by the way
predates the law of moses when when god
starts telling the children of israel
here are the feast of the agricultural
cycle
that wasn't the first time that they'd
ever heard of them or celebrated them
right he's just telling them here's how
you celebrate these
in a way that
shows that you're my people right
but everyone basically has these feasts
and more or less with certain variations
pretty much every culture in the world
that lives within the same kind of
climate and climate cycle
has the feast right around the same
points in time okay
so what universal history does you know
one thing that we've talked about is the
way that universal history shows how a
group of people
try to tie themselves into
the christian and the roman story yeah
right but another thing that universal
history does that's kind of part of this
in this broader expansive
way that i'm using the term
is it shows how how how does my daily
life
tie into that
story
and so
in so sometimes people will make a big
deal about the fact that for instance in
um
in like celtic paganism they had these
sort of quarters of the year and these
were the days that fell exactly between
the each solstice and equinox right
there's one on this date
right um in in ireland that it was
celebrated on uh february the 1st
which happens to also be the feast day
of st bridget of kildare it was actually
the the patron state of my new daughter
so there you go
um it's all connected um
but uh
and so people will make a big deal about
this and and they'll be like oh this is
just like see it's just a christianizing
of this older pagan thing and
again to that i have to say one
i don't care i know you guys can be
complaining we'll we'll baptize shark
week like i'm sure you've seen that meme
it's like listen if you guys keep you
guys keep complaining about this stuff
we're going to make shark week a
christian holiday like that's right
uh but but i mean uh in another sense
you have to realize that this is the
this is the way that things work right
this is the way that that
we we that reality manifests and this is
the way that we know
each other and the world that we live in
and it's the way that we know god right
is the way that these things manifest
themselves in time in the cycles the
recurring cycles of the seasons which
were made
by god
right and so it's kind of like
preposterous
to think and this is why i just
i get heartburn from these people who
are like oh well this you know
um a long time ago when i was a pastor
of a church there was a big fraucus
because we we had a christmas tree up in
like the the foyer the foyer you know
which is what baptists called the nerf x
you know yeah and uh and uh some people
are like oh well yeah and you know like
chris
you know that's a pagan holiday and they
sent me like this dvd series
you know like
you know you gotta tell the christmas
exactly
right
i know you know what i'm talking about
right but the reason that stuff gives me
heartburn is is because it's like you
know you think god doesn't own the days
of the year like he made the year he
made the agricultural cycle he made the
solstices and the equinox you know like
he made these things
and
so why would he not when he manifests
himself in the world
right when he becomes incarnate he
becomes incarnate
taking on human nature in this full
complete total way
but he also like becomes incarnate at a
particular point in time at a particular
place in history
but what the
what the whole sort of christian year
shows
is the way in which
that
particularity
you could say again like the the glory
of the people israel
becomes a light to the nations right and
so and so christ doesn't just fill up
the 33 years that he's walking around on
planet earth yeah but actually fills up
all of time with himself right so
there's no other way that this stuff
could manifest right this is a feature
it's not a bug
exactly
um
and understanding the relationship of
the times of the year uh to the life of
christ
via the christian liturgical year is
vital it's absolutely vital to the
reading of medieval literature
uh just to take as a for instance
arthurian literature every great
arthurian story happens
at a particular christian feast day yeah
sometimes it's pentecost sometimes it's
christmas
sir gowen in the green night happens
on the feast not of christmas
one of my many i mean happens during
christmas tied but doesn't happen on
christmas day which is one of my many
beefs with a recent film yeah it happens
on the feast of the circumcision of the
lord which was very popular in england
at the time that that poem was written
yeah and also it's like don't you if you
cut something a a monster in two and you
don't
understand that there's a relationship
between the circumcision and that yeah
and that it's like you're missing out on
some of the story
and i don't wanna i don't wanna like i
don't wanna sound impious about this
okay but first of all you have to
understand in the middle ages people
thought this was a pretty good joke
right there's a beheading it happens on
the feast of the circumcision of the
lord like like people
people were aware right but also like if
you don't unders if you don't understand
that that story begins on the feast of
the circumcision you won't actually
understand anything
about the story yeah right which is like
what to do with the remainder exactly
that's what the whole story is about
that's what the whole story is about i
mean it's about you know like the sash
and everything is always about it's
always about that it's yeah so and so uh
yeah and so if you don't understand this
stuff then you won't be able to read
medieval literature right um
and and kind of know what it's about so
to me like if you want to understand
something like medieval universal
history one of the most important things
you need to do is say well how did
how did a certain group of people
how did they celebrate this feast what
did they do for christmas what did they
do for easter would they do for
um if you want to understand like who
they really were
and what they thought about themselves
it's not just how did they write
themselves into
the larger narrative on this really meta
cultural level
but how did they see themselves being as
being a part of that story in their
day-to-day life for instance candlemas
england huge deal huge deal
and in fact
if you were if you were if you lived in
a town that was large enough
uh to do this um
uh most candleless candlemas
celebrations were celebrated by a sort
of mystery place procession before mass
so you'd get one of the women of the
town to dress up like the virgin mary
um which of course for them meant you
should dress her as beautifully as you
could afford to do right
um because they weren't interested in
the fact that okay yes obviously mary
just were quite poor
you know
for them it was it was you know this is
they're trying to show her as as who she
is right she's the queen of heaven she's
the mother of god right so we want to we
want to show that in the way that we
dress her so they would dress dress her
up
you'd have an older man in the town
playing joseph uh she would be carrying
like a little doll right and then you'd
have a whole procession right a whole
procession
with everyone bringing again bearing
candles everybody would light their
candles and they'd bear them together in
this big procession to the parish church
and then they'd have like an older man
meet you at the door of the parish
church and you'd come in and what would
you do you'd celebrate mass
and of course receive the eucharist
right so there's this whole
you know there was like this very you
know it was very festival there are
whole carols like we know about
christmas carols right but there
actually used to be carols for
everything
and christmas carols are the only things
that have really survived because
christmas for most people like living in
the west most evangelicals is kind of
the last
surviving vestige of the christian year
like even more so than easter yeah um
you're right yeah even more so than
easter like i know that you know at the
churches where i served
christmas is a much bigger deal than
easter right um
and
and and that's when you know even a
baptist church like they'll break out
the nativity scene they'll put some
graven images right up there in front of
the pulpit for everyone to look at for
the entire month of december you know
it's it's kind of but it's just like
when christmas hits
that's when our nostalgia really kicks
in
for not just for like how did my family
celebrate but also like a wider cultural
nostalgic kind of kicks in and we do
things and we sing these really old
songs those are oldest hymns in any
given protestant hymnal are always going
to be your christmas carols right that
go back you know as early as the 15th
16th century right before the
reformation right
um
and it's just like when we hit christmas
a certain nostalgia kicks in
but there used to be carols for
everything and there are beautiful
interesting fascinating
carols even sandal mass carols candle
miss carols even some written by
puritans in uh like colonial
williamsburg wow um uh in fact um
can i just read you a couple is that
okay did we sure it's up to you yeah
all right so um uh one thing that to
know about candlemiss so this is like a
a little kind of a superstition around
cannabis is that cannabis is actually
when you're supposed to take your
christmas decorations down right so you
put them up on christmas eve you take
them down on candlebus
we took them out on epiphany yeah well
let me just read you
all right
there's a little bit of a conflict there
all right so this one this one is a poem
from colonial williamsburg okay
when new year's day is past and gone
christmas is with some people done so
some people stop celebrating christmas
on new year's day right but further some
will it extend and at 12th day their
christmas end which is where you go
that's me yes
at candle and some people stretch it
further yet
at candlemas they finish it the gentry
carry it further still and finish it
just when they will they keep good wine
and eat good cheer and keep their
christmas all the year
so so some people
some people are always partying right
and i do have neighbors who keep their
christmas lights up just all year long
um and i don't know what's going on
there but they seem like we tend to
creep the christmas lights outside
people tend to keep them at towards the
until the end of uh of winter yeah yeah
yeah yeah but the inside the inside
decorations go down
yeah christmas lights like aren't quite
the
they're not quite as good as a holy
candle
but in our in our modern age they're
pretty darn close they're pretty close
that's um
yeah i'm a big fan of like please just
like make your yards go crazy on
christmas i think that's great so this
uh i'll but i'll read this other one
this is right um this real quick this is
like um this is like a late 1500s this
is a candleless carol
um it's called down with the rosemary
and so and you can find like people
singing on youtube but it goes like this
down with the rosemary and so down with
the base and mistletoe down with the
holly ivy all wherewithy dressed the
christmas hall so that the superstitious
find no one least branch there left
behind for look how many leaves there be
neglected there maids trust to me so
many goblins you shall see so it's like
it's like for every like for every like
leaf of christmas decoration you leave
out you're gonna have that near god
after candleness right so uh yeah so
it's so it's it's uh
and
and that's kind of like a silly little
rhyme but you can again see there's
something about the day going back to
simeon's prophecy right it's this
revelation of light but it's also
there's some kind of a prediction
of the monstrous of something something
that's going to happen
so
um all of this is i think pretty
important to understanding uh so where
where did we get groundhog day from all
right let's go groundhog day now so
groundhog day
um
in uh
in various places in europe
this day february the
um probably because of some
well for all the reasons that we just
talked about right you're halfway
between the winter solstice and the
spring equinox right all this stuff
became a day of what you could call
what's sometimes called weather lore
or whether mancy
right so it's basically trying to
predict the weather
how
good of a spring like how good of a
spring are we gonna have when can we
start planting like all this different
stuff right it's all tied up tied up on
this stuff
and um and so
what happened
is that in pretty much all western uh
european traditions they started using
the weather on candlemaster
which again hits at this midpoint but
it's significant for these other
spiritual reasons
and for them like in the middle ages if
you were like well there's like a
meteorological reason
and then a spiritual reason and like if
you tried to tell somebody in the middle
ages that those were just like separate
things that didn't have anything to do
with each other nobody would
they'd look at you like you're a crazy
person right and they'd be right yeah
they'd be right so they use the the
candleless weather to predict the
beginning of spring and usually
in germany the the the animal in
question was actually a badger
um
and so in fact in nova scotia yeah um
which is up in canadia or so i'm told
um
uh it's called dox day with docs being
like the the the german word for a
badger yeah okay so not not groundhog
day but doc's day
um
sometimes also though it's a fox or a
bear for our purposes it can basically
be any hibernating animal like anything
that goes to sleep in the winter and
then wakes up in the spring interesting
for the bear how would they get the bear
to come out of during hibernation sounds
a little trickier well that's why they
tended to use badgers
um
an angry badger is still uh
a handful let's say but not not quite to
the level that an angry bear is that's
right grumpy angry right so when the
pennsylvania dutch when they uh they're
these are like basically immigrants from
german-speaking areas of europe and they
migrated to this part of pennsylvania
where there were no badgers but what did
they have that hibernated in the winter
groundhogs
right permits right and so that's kind
of the that's kind of the um
that's kind of the origin
of that so basically what you have is
there's this obscure weather lore
practice
that is
what's not obscure it's like pretty
widely practiced but it's on the fringe
of the thing that the feast is about
yeah
and in the united states
we've totally forgotten the feast
right
we've totally forgotten the feast
but everyone remembers the little minor
weather lore practice that's associated
like halloween you know right
right how americans celebrate their
holidays right
right
yeah like we take we take the fringe
thing and the grip the gift giving
that's the that's the feast you take the
the monsters coming out that's the feast
and now the right now the the badgers
things that like yeah and so we take the
we take the thing that's sort of like
the fringe part of the celebration of
the holiday which there's nothing wrong
with that no it is place it's fine
but then that's the we we take that
thing we put it in the center it becomes
the most essential thing right
um but i do want to talk real quick now
now that we kind of understand like the
background and kind of this you know the
the spiritual and medieval map of of
this feast
to talk about what it means for
the groundhog to see its shadow
and to go back into hibernation
right so
the whole idea of seeing its shadow
is that it's clear and sunny
on the day
right
you're in the middle of winter right now
right so six weeks into winter you've
got six more weeks of winter coming
so if it's the middle of winter
and in this particular climate like
northern european climate
and it's bright and sunny and kind of a
warm day
such that this animal which is coming
out of death right it's coming out of
sleep is coming out of the earth comes
up out of death it sees the light but
you could say it like sees the light too
soon
and so it turns around and goes back
right back into back into death right
there's almost something that seems to
me to be here uh
about about kind of the dangers of you
call it like the danger of premature
enlightenment or the danger of unearned
wisdom right
um in a way
it's almost related to like you know the
parable of the sower goes out to sow the
seed and some of the some of the seed
falls on rocky ground and it springs up
really quick and then the sun comes out
and it withers and dies because it it
had sprung up so fast in the shallow
earth that wasn't able to put any roots
down
um
and so uh
well or what about i'm surprised that
you see it that way like i would tend to
see it as something like
the the
light casts a shadow right right and so
you have this sense that when when light
arrives it both reveals the light but it
also reveals the darkness so that's why
simeon says
this is for the rise and fall of many
right in in israel right so the badger
the the the badger comes out
and the question is which way is it
going to go
is it going to go towards the light or
is it going to go towards the darkness
so if it sees the darkness
then it goes back into darkness and if
it sees the light then it comes out into
the light so you could see the the
moment of revelation
has a kind of it's always like a double
revelation which is why that's how
christ presents it as
as uh you know as exactly what simeon
says like as as something which reveals
both the glory and the scandal yeah
right all things will be revealed and so
you actually see the sins of everybody
and you also see
the the goodness in the world so that
seems to be something like that which is
that
that would be the way i would interpret
it no i think you're right and i i don't
see this
let me try to reframe what i'm saying a
little bit right because um
you could say there's a
right so man is microcosm right that's
the most important medieval idea right
if you want to understand anything about
how they thought about the world in the
middle ages or medieval literature
you got to be able to understand what
does it mean for a man to be a microcosm
of of the cosmos right like a little
cosmos
so on a cosmic scale
the ultimate day of revelation is the
last judgment right
when you know the fire of god the light
of god
reveals
light and darkness
but then also in some kind of a in some
kind of a way like a participatory way
that day is pasca right right that's the
day when we say let god arise and let
his enemies be scattered right that's
the day of his uprising that's the day
when he scatters the enemies of god
up and he invites
he invites those are who are his right
into the light right
and then on a personal level you could
say
that that moment
this is what say maximus the confessor
says he says that the the moment of
the dismissal of the catechumens in the
divine liturgy corresponds to
participates in the moment of the last
judgment
so so that's the moment where
you you you sort of cast out you send
out the people who are not
ready for the light yeah right and then
those that are now they get to come
receive it how do they receive it is in
the eucharist which is kind of what this
this feast the mystery of this feast is
about
that's an interesting idea like it's
also it seems related also to the idea
of adam and eve because you could also
see it that way like yeah i mean
they eat that not the the the
the the fruit of the knowledge of good
and evil and then they move let's say
towards the tree of life and that light
exposes their shadow in their case like
they see their shadow they they're
they're ashamed of that which is reveals
you could say yeah and then they turn
back into their hole and try to hide
themselves
so
yeah that's that's exactly it like
that's that's exactly it so i i kind of
see those things like i don't think i
don't think these takes are like
contradiction no they're not right yeah
um because you could say it's something
like something like trying to take
communion too soon like if you were a
catechumen and you went up and you you
tried to take communion like it would be
to your judgment right it'd be to your
judgment um i've seen priests say like
i'm not like if a non-orthodox person
comes up he says yeah i'm not going to
give you communion not because of me
because you i want to protect you from
right fire basically right yeah
so
this is also i think very closely
associated with the idea of lent
so the way to kind of think about lent
right is you know because we start lent
literally with the last judgment
right yeah you know that's that's you
know meat fair sunday right it's a
sunday of the last judgment so we begin
lent actually with the last judgment so
it's it's exposing here's who you are
and here's who you aren't right and for
most of us that's just not a great
experience like most of us if we're
really honest with ourselves and we
listen to the gospel on the sunday at
the last judgment
and we start to say well i haven't fed
christ i haven't clothed him i haven't
visited him in prison you know et cetera
right
so then what do you do you go back you
kind of go back into death right and so
your life becomes more austere the true
services become
uh
more uh solemn and even you know darker
like you see the six weeks of the of the
the badger or the the marmot as lent
basically
so
so it's six weeks long okay
so in groundhog day the film
right
i've often heard people basically say
the movies about purgatory yeah right
which is not wrong but
yeah it's the same it's similar yeah so
here's what's interesting um there have
been a lot of film theories you can go
out there and find
how many days did he do like how many
times did you do groundhog day right
over and over again you can find like
how many times you know
and some people say well to to learn all
the information that he learned it had
to have been like 10 000 years or so you
know something insane okay yeah
taking that stuff aside
the original script and the notes the
director had it be like a thousand years
but in the final script the one that
actually got filmed in in the in the
director's notes for the film
he has it as a 40-day period nice
so
it's 40 days of what of basically
learning how to repent yeah right that's
what groundhog day is it's 40 days of
learning how to repent not repentance is
just saying oh i'm sorry
my bad right that's not repentance what
is repentance it's it's turning around
it's a change of mind it's a change of
heart and that's basically
what phil in that movie who is the
groundhog right he is the groundhog
right in fact at one point he he
kidnapped the actual groundhog and like
they drive off a cliff together because
he's just like wants to end all of this
right but what is he doing he's going
back down into the earth yeah he's going
back down he's going back
with the groundhog right yeah and so for
fun
that's what happens when you wake up in
the morning and the day
the groundhog hasn't hasn't moved on the
ground of god's gone back into his cave
and trying to stay in that cave
until the sun the sun is really ready
he's ready to see the sun like you said
yeah yeah and so it's and so when he's
able to actually see the light
and not be scared by his own shadow
right and you know you could go a whole
direction with just talking about the
shadow right but when he's when he's not
able when he's able to not be terrified
by his own shadow in other words his sin
right this this false personality it's
not really true to himself you know it's
just like the armor that he's built up
against the world around him that's when
he's able to enter into this loving
relationship
and that's what
that's possible right that's what breaks
the the spell that's when he gets out
right nice so
anyway i think that's amazing i i i it's
so once we see it it's actually so
obvious right there's a relationship
between between all these things yeah
but i never have thought about groundhog
day ever in my life even though i
enjoyed the movie but i didn't
i watched it so long ago that i wasn't
thinking about symbolism at that at that
time so i didn't think about
how it could be related to
to uh
to to lent and to pasca into the idea of
you know like
let's say uh
purging your your passions in order to
be ready to uh to emerge let's say yeah
that's wonderful yeah
so that's that's all that's right hug
day yeah that's a great thing this is
great stuff yeah so this is a like i
said i i hope that people understand uh
maybe it's just the last thing i hope
people sort of can start to see the
connection between this and the broader
idea of universal history right is that
you have to think of history
as being in you can think of it as like
a series of fractals or wheels within
wheels or however you want to talk about
it right
of you've got here's the story of
history right um this is this is what uh
vodalovskin in like loras right gets
this so beautifully right he he
understands this so well is history is
not a it's not just a line
right it's not a complete circle it's
more like a spiral right yeah but the
way that you live that spiral out is in
the cycle of the christian year right as
you're moving towards the end of history
and people get hung up about okay well
when is that when is the end of history
well the short answer this is also in
loras okay the short answer is the end
of history is when you die
right yeah like don't don't worry about
like when is you know the the last
judgment or the rapture like don't worry
about whenever that is supposed to
happen the thing that you know is going
to happen is that you're going to die
right and for you that is that is the
last judgment right exactly
and so um
yeah so
to to understand the way that you
actually participate in that psych in
that spiral you could say
is by attaching yourself to the
christian year
uh which has left
many little remnants like little ruins
in the world around us today things like
groundhog day right well when ground dog
when groundhog day comes around this
year instead of saying
oh what a stupid thing i guess i guess
we have six more weeks of winter because
a rodent in the ground in pennsylvania
says we do
you know
go to church get a holy candle light it
keep out the darkness right and wait for
the light of pasca
well thanks for that you know this is
great and so don't worry everybody we
will
we will back with uh more universal
history we're gonna we're gonna go back
into some arthur and move on to the
millions of things we we could talk
about in terms of universe history so
richard thanks again this was really uh
this was just a nice surprise for me and
thanks for everybody for paying
attention and we'll talk to you very
soon
hey symbolic world gang um i just wanted
to take a quick moment to tack on to
this video about universal history and
the symbolism of groundhog day
uh to actually mention to you something
that's gonna be happening in the north
texas area so if you are able to get
yourself down there towards the end of
the month of february 2022 we are
hosting an orthodox arts festival so
this is the festival orthodox christian
art it's being hosted by saints
constantine and helen antioquine
orthodox church in carrollton texas so
it's the north part of dallas
it's february the 18th through the 20th
check out orthodox artsfestivaldfw.com
we'll put a link in the description of
this youtube video again that's orthodox
arts
festivaldfw.com and you can get all the
information that you need to have about
how to get tickets uh and what the
schedule is going to be
we've got a ton of great speakers um
we've got a keynote address on the role
of the arts and orthodox theology by
peter button off currently he teaches
theology spirituality in the arts at st
vladimir's orthodox seminary he just
actually finished co-editing an amazing
book
on uh arvo part
and he also has a podcast called
luminous conversations on sacred arts
which has all kinds of stuff all kinds
of really really interesting stuff you
guys would enjoy they're also on
saturday there's going to be
presentations workshops and
demonstrations by local orthodox artists
and also people who like to talk about
these things like me i'm going to be
giving a talk on literature and the
sacramental imagination there's going to
be a bunch of other really great people
there including some symbolic world
folks josh sturgill from the 8th day
institute he'll be there he'll be
talking deacon anthony stokes going to
be talking about beauty and liturgy the
role of quality music in our worship
and some other great talks on writing on
architecture in the orthodox tradition
on reading on how to actually like look
at and study icons it's going to be a
lot of great stuff there's going to be
they're going to be some films that will
be shown there as well
and some workshops some hands-on stuff
and demonstrations um and that will all
end with pan orthodox vespers at 5 p.m
on saturday so anyway it's going to be a
great event and i look forward to seeing
you there if you're looking for me i'm
the tall
orthodox guy with a beard
you